the window object is supported by all
browsers it represents the browser's
window all global JavaScript objects
functions and variables automatically
become members of the window object even
the document object from the Dom is part
of the window object so if you look here
document dot get element by ID and we
have demo here this is actually part of
the window object because the word
window is implied is actually window
document dot get element by ID demo each
tab in a browser contains its own window
object the window object contains many
properties and methods in this video I
will go over getting a window size and
opening closing and moving a window in
other videos I will talk more about
other things you can do with the window
object so you can already see this code
here when you see the only HTML is just
this P tag with the ID demo and we're
going to get that tag here and then
we're going to run the update function
and also we have a window to add event
listener on resize we're going to run
the update function so in the update
function we're just going to set the
inner HTML of this element here this
demo element we're going to set to be
this text right here you see part of
text is window inner width and window
enter height so that's how you get the
height and width of the window and
because we have this add event listener
with resize anytime we resize the window
it's going to update those numbers so if
you look here as I resize the window
those numbers are updating to the actual
height and width of the window ok now I
will show you how to use the window
object to open a new window so here
we're going to create a variable called
new window option the window dot open
command so we're going to pass in three
different arguments to this function
first argument is the web address that
we're trying to open and then it's going
to be the name of the window that we can
refer to later and then it's going to be
the options so there are a lot of
options you can set and I'm going to try
to run this so it will it will open the
window
okay you can see it popped up this
window right here I'm going to move it
just to the side here not all the
options are available in every browser
so even though it says resize will fall
scroll bars false well there is a scroll
bar here and look I can resize this but
in some other browsers these these would
work but some of the things that do work
are the width and height 400 pixels and
300 pixels and in the top and left
that's where the window originally
showed up so if I change the width to
500 in the height to 600 I can change
the top to 100 and the left to 400 and
we'll just see what happens here I only
closed that and run this again okay so
you can see it pops up in a different
place this time okay well let's change
those back for now though and now I'm
just going to add something right to the
HTML right in the HTML code I'm going to
add this button with value close window
and on click it's going to called new
window ABS close so this new window of
the name of this variable here and
that's how we'll know which which window
to run the close function on so let's
try that if I hit run it's going to open
the window now let me just move the
window over here so when I click the
button you'll still see the other window
in the background click close window and
it closes now you may be wondering here
we use this new window object comes from
down here but what about the name over
here the new window name well that's
what you use if you're going to target a
link so let me put in a link here and
you can see we're going to go to this
other website that's my my website and
I'm going to target new window and
that's where that name comes in down
here so let's try that I popped open the
window move this aside so you can see it
click the link and it updates the
webpage in that new window the last
thing I'm going to show you in this
video is moving a window so let me add
another button here so you can see on
click is going to call the move
so we have to create the move function
down here and when the move function
runs it's going to call new window abu
by and they want to put how many pixels
we're going to move by so it's going to
move fifty pixels left and zero pixels
down you can also do move too and then
we'll go to an exact coordinate on the
screen this focus command here that's
just going to pop the window up to the
top of the screen so if the window is
behind another window focus will make it
pop up to the top of the screen when we
first try this though it's not going to
work if I click run to pop up the window
and then I move this to the side that
click move window it's not going to move
that's because of the cores error if I
open up the JavaScript error console
you'll see it's it just just says block
the frame with origin code pin because
I'm using code pin from accessing a
cross origin frame so this would work if
I wasn't doing it through code 10 but
there's a way to just demonstrate this
and not have the air so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to close this window
and here we're opening a specific
address I'm just going to delete that so
now it's going to open a window but it's
not going to load a website into that
window so let's run that and see it
opens up just a blank window and now
when I click move window see it moves
over and you can see that when I click
the this website with has the move
window button the window goes behind
this window but if I click move window
it moves and it jumps into focus here so
it pops back up so if I move it here
they comes maybe see it move better so
just keep moving and then we can still
load the website and we can still close
the window well thanks for watching the
coach of this video is like always in
the description stay tuned for more
videos about the window object my name
is beau Carnes and remember use your
code for good